ils sont passés presque directement des
compositions de la saint valentin aux
plants de légumes du potager sans
s'arrêter à la case des pensées de
printemps ou des tulipes de pâques dans
le secteur agricole les horticulteurs
sont les grands perdants du confinement
quand même énormément de pertes sur les
productions de printemps comme les
pensées les vivas tout ça c'était une
grosse grosse perte c'est des
productions qu'on commence à l'automne
donc c'est vrai que ça présente des mois
de travail et aussi une perte financière
énorme
cet horticulteur damagnez a dû lui aussi
détruire 50 mille plants de fleurs
bisannuelles en mars et en avril
il déplore qu'aucune aide n'était prévu
pour son secteur par l'europe ou par
l'état
vendredi son syndicat a rencontré le
ministre de l'agriculture didier
guillaume pour lui lancer un sos
une rencontre a eu lieu pour travailler
sur trois axes à la fois un axe au
niveau de l'europe pour avoir un
dédommagement au niveau des plans qui
ont été détruites un axe au niveau d'une
exonération de charges par rapport à la
période où on a dû être confinés
le troisième axe de soutien va concerner
la communication on espère que les gens
vont revenir nous voir consommer des
végétaux d'ornement et on compte sur le
gouvernement pour assurer la promotion
de nos produits des produits régionaux
certifié éco responsable depuis lundi
c'est ce que viennent de nouveau
chercher des habitués dans les serres de
cet horticulteur
je suis venue acheter des fleurs pour un
peu le jardin et pour le film pierrot
chine une composition puisque les
cimetières ont rouvert il ya bon c'est
un peu dans un état où il faut aller
désherber il ya beaucoup de choses à
faire
je suis fleurissent à besançon donc je
vais à m'approvisionner régulièrement
chez simon courbet parce que de
production locale non et on est très
on utilise beaucoup de fleurs de la
région le plus que possible pour
compenser leurs 70 % de perte de ces
deux derniers mois
les horticulteurs de bourgogne franche
comté espère que les collectivités et
les paysagistes se fourniront eux aussi
chez eux plutôt que chez leurs
concurrents belges ou hollandais